let's take the derivative
with respect to x
of x to the n plus one power over n plus
one
plus some constant c and we're going to
assume here because we want this
expression to be defined we're going to
assume that n
does not equal negative 1 if it equals
negative 1 we'd be dividing by 0 and
that would we haven't defined what that
means so let's take the derivative here
so this is going to be equal to well the
derivative of x to the n plus one over n
plus one we can just use the power rule
over here
so our exponent is n plus one we can
bring it out front so it's going to be n
plus one
times x
to the i want to use that same color
colors are the hard part
times x to the instead of n plus 1 we
subtract 1 from the exponent this is
just the power rule so n plus 1 minus 1
is going to be n and then we can't
forget that we have we were dividing by
this n plus 1. so we have divided by n
plus 1
and then we have plus c the derivative
of a constant with respect to x a
constant does not change as x changes so
it is just going to be 0. so plus
0.
and since n is not equal negative 1 we
know that this is going to be defined
this is just going to be something
divided by itself which is just going to
be 1 and this whole thing simplifies to
x
to the n so the derivative of this thing
and this is in very general terms is
equal to x to the n so given that
given that what is the antiderivative
let me switch colors here
what is
what is the antiderivative
of x to the n
of x to the n and remember this is just
the kind of strange looking notation we
use it'll make more sense when we start
doing definite integrals but what is the
antiderivative of x to the n and we
could say the antiderivative with
respect to x if we want to
and another way of calling this is the
indefinite integral in
definite
integral
well we know this is saying x to the n
is the derivative of what well we just
figured out it's the derivative of this
thing and we've written it in very
general terms we're actually
encapsulating
multiple constants here we could have a
x to the n plus 1 over n plus 1 plus 0
plus 1 plus 2 plus pi plus a billion so
this is going to be equal to
x to the n plus 1
over n plus 1
plus
c
so this is pretty powerful you can kind
of view this as the reverse
the reverse power rule and it applies
it applies for any n as long as n does
not equal negative one let me make that
very clear n
does not equal n does not equal negative
1. once again this thing would be
undefined if n were equal to negative 1.
so let's do a couple of examples just to
apply this you could call it the reverse
power rule if you want or the anti-power
rule so let's take the anti-derivative
of
x to the fifth power
what is the anti-derivative of x to the
fifth
well all we have to say is well look the
five is equal to the n we just have to
increment the exponent by one so this is
going to be equal to x to the five plus
one power and then we divide by that
that same value whatever the exponent
was when you increment it by one we
divide by that same value divided by 5
plus 1 and of course we want to
encapsulate all of the possible
anti-derivatives so you put the c right
over there so this is going to be equal
to
x to the sixth
over 6
plus c and you can verify take the
derivative of this using the power rule
you indeed get x to the fifth
let's try another one
let's try and i'll do it in blue
let's try the anti-derivative of
let's make it interesting let's make it
5 times x to the negative 2 power
dx
so how would we evaluate this
well one simplification you can do and
i'm not re i haven't rigorously proven
it to you just yet but we know that
scalars can go in and out of the
derivative operator when you're
multiplying by a scalar so this is
indeed equal to 5 times the
antiderivative
of x to the negative 2 power dx and now
we can just use we could i guess we
could call it this anti-power rule so
this is going to be equal to 5 times
x to the negative 2 power plus 1
plus 1
over the negative 2 power plus 1 plus
some constant
plus some constant right over here
and if we and then we can rewrite this
as 5 times negative 2 power plus 1 is x
to the negative 1
over negative 2 plus 1 is negative 1
plus some constant and this is equal to
this is equal to 5 times negative
x to the negative 1 plus some constant
and then if we want we can distribute
the 5. so this is equal to negative 5
x to the negative 1. now we could write
plus 5 times some constant but this is
just an arbitrary constant so this is
still just an arbitrary constant so
maybe we could written of this if you
wanted to show us a different constants
you could say this is c1 c1 c1 you
multiply 5 times c1 you get another
constant we could just call that c which
is equal to 5 times c1
but there you have it negative 5 x to
the negative 1 plus
c and once again all of these try to
evaluate the derivative and you will see
that you get you get this business right
over there